that's playful okey-dokey what can I do
for you
something tribal Chinese I don't do
curse words in any language well we are
looking to bar something so we may make
it bill because we've run out of things
that we smell what are you guys doing we
want to buy some ring so that we can put
in our bear in you know spike a bear
smoke a ding smoking one of them I got a
pack you get an apple and then we can
eat guys man love the energy but you
can't hang out here the space is for
customers okay there we go huh Oh looks
so beautiful
Brinson oh that hurt a little you know
it would numb the pain weed Oh get the
wrong guy pal
okay you winked earlier those can I at
least get the stud that I paid for
I'm bummed dude this is a bust
no not a bust you got a banging ass
belly button rings you did honestly I
don't even know if I'm gonna keep you Oh
cub don't say that as banging ass
banging is it is how're you guys we're
asking for you might be able to help you
out you me I'm back in ten minutes
hey make it 15
I want to go to that pet store next door
you